so i'll be presenting today a platinum a
platform that we have been working on
for the last few years aiming at
federating the tools and infrastructures
of data size into one consistent
framework that makes the access to data
the access to technical computing
environments and the access to cloud
computing infrastructures as seamless as
it could be so we have rebranded from
elastic are to rosetta hub in order to
maybe reduce the our connection that we
started with but ended up having
something that is completely generic
where a python is the first class
citizens as our is so i would have demos
i think there is an issue with the Wi-Fi
it's blocking web sockets so maybe some
some features will not be as as they
should be in the demo but let's let's
start basically bye-bye few slides to
explain what this is about so basically
what we try to achieve is to basically
create an open platform inside which
everything you may need in order to
interact with your data becomes a
component that can be plugged easily of
course in Python we have already
components those modules are something
that anyone can create and distribute
and you can just from one link get that
component to deliver into your workbench
capabilities that could be algorithm
could be anything that someone coded for
you and that someone shared for you the
idea of the platform is to say we need a
connector for a technical computing
environment that would be universal in
the sense that I will be able to access
not only a Python Moodle but I would be
as easily connect to our that runs on
the cloud get our to do something for me
get results back if I need to continue
using Julia then I will connect to the
Julia a personality of the remote engine
and in order for this to be seamless we
needed to create a federation layer 44
data we want you to be able to say from
your Python command line this is my new
empire matrix please send it to our our
should receive it seamlessly become a
matrix in our you do your computation
you get a result bring it back to your
local Python command line and then if
you wish to continue using a spark
cluster then you push the data to this
scalar a personality of the same engine
and keep going so basically we created
these Rosetta objects that map your
vectors your metrics your data frames
whatever you use in these different
technical computing environment we
created bridges that can pull and push
that type of data so this is the
connectivity as it relates to to a
technical computing environment now we
wanted something that allow you actually
to be able to interact with an
infrastructure could it be amazon could
it be google compute engine could it be
your local cluster or could it be your
Raspberry Pi we would like something
that makes infrastructure looks and
feels as if it is electricity you have
had this metaphor several times everyone
when it comes to cloud computing they
say yep basically the utility computing
you plug to that big data center and get
computation done but in order for this
to fill and to look and to be accessible
like an electricity plug it takes more
than the api's of a cloud computing
infrastructure it needs some more
interaction design to reach this level
of seamlessness so that's what we
achieved so we created on top of the
existing infrastructures the existing
clouds could they be private or public a
common framework that you can talk to
from your path and come online that you
can talk to from your browser from Excel
from anywhere
in order to achieve this integration
Federation when it comes to user
interfaces and to interaction so we
wanted something maybe some of you know
of shiny who used Chinese already in the
room okay so shiny allows you to create
interactive web applications on top of
our functions on top of our scripts and
data it's people like it because very
quickly and without being a web
developer you can create a service and
share it with with with the others it's
not like sharing a function it's it's
something that can handle scenarios
where someone who knows our can deliver
something that's something useful to
someone who doesn't know our think of a
bioinformaticians sending something to a
biologist the biologists will be playing
with those sliders and looking at those
visualization according to the data sets
coming from the experiments and our is
hidden at how shiny works it's it's
based on what we call reactive
programming so what we wanted here is to
take these this framework from
conceptual point of view and generalize
it to any environment could it be Python
could it be Julia could it be
Mathematica whatever tools are
accessible through this connector could
benefit from this reactive programming
framework and we tried also to make
reactive programming as easy as possible
those who use Chinese would maybe
recognize that it's tricky really to
write that server code that client code
is not for everyone it's not for
statisticians it's not who are not geeks
at the same time you know so we try to
imagine a way for this reactive
programming to be as intuitive as as
simple as possible and and to be also
uniform so a consistent uniform object
model that can be sent back and forth to
any technical computing environment a
consistent reactive programming model
that would allow you to create
interactive web applications interactive
services on top of any of those a
consistent framework for infrastructure
that makes all of them look the same
conceptually they all become like a
virtual one consistent cloud if you wish
we wanted something that makes access to
data and storages seamless basically
connectors to whatever storage you may
want to access to the HDFS could be as
three could be wherever your data is
living on top of this we needed to make
this platform accessible to to any
environment to any language to any tool
you may be using on your local computer
so we created basically all the api's
are in soap and restful and we have HTTP
ApS that that come with clients in vba
in java in skala whatever language you
need you will find something that would
allow you to talk to this platform and
say hey these are my credentials to
Amazon please create for me a an engine
for doing computation that understands
our and understands Python so you will
be doing this from your clients and and
forget about the agility of the clouds
the differences that may exist between
Google compute engine and and ec2 and so
on and so forth we wanted also to make
the generation of services on top of
functions that you may create in Python
or are or Julia as seamless as possible
so basically the platform would allow
you to point the functions let's say
this is a normalization function and say
to the platform please expose it as a
soap web service or expose it to my
excel as a vba function that i can use
from from my my local excel spreadsheet
so this is the ambition and what's
what's the aim what's the why why we
wanted this the key word here is
empowerment the cloud is something
amazing it's it's really
a bunch of capabilities that data
scientists can use and and can help them
in being more productive than ever but
in order for the cloud work for everyone
we need to make it accessible we need to
make it user-friendly we need to create
the layers that connect that cloud to
the tools that you you are already using
in a way that is convenient and simple
empowerment means also that we have to
automate everything that can be
automated so Amazon did something
amazing by making infrastructure become
code and by making the automation happen
when it comes to servers and to storage
and to whatever artifacts related to IT
we'd like to complete the picture and
get the automation to to cover all the
spectrum that would be of interest to a
data scientist so this this picture
shows you a this idea of Rosetta virtual
cloud basically because we have created
this broker capable of yet taking your
credentials to any cloud and and going
to that particular cloud and creating
for you these engines with which you can
interact from your browser to have to
have an accession of Python in your iPad
or to have a notebook in your cell phone
so these engines are created by this
broker here using your own credentials
which means that this machine is being
paid for by you because it's your
account what we do here is be an
intermediary or a broker that helps you
make this happen without knowing how to
use easy to without knowing how to use
GC so here you see a user who is talking
to this a broker and through this broker
is interacting with different public
clouds or or eventually private clouds
those who here who are familiar AWS
maybe just question who used already
easy 20 amazing who used already
Google's compute engine if you wonderful
so all these things are kind of in a
common places in order to basically AWS
gives you a web console from which you
can create your servers your and
allocate your storage and gives you a
command-line interface that allow you to
do exactly the same thing but in a
scripted fashion you can go even further
with script ability in using the api's
and the SDKs directly so you can have a
python package from which you ask amazon
to allocate servers and to create for
you whatever is needed to store your
data what we want what what Rosetta hub
is about we want you two to see no
border line anymore between the
infrastructure and the data and the code
what I mean by this we want you to keep
control and to have api's and web
console SDKs but to manipulate artifacts
that are meaningful to you to manipulate
engines for data processing to
manipulate data sets of a particular
type of particular kind we want you
basically to have in your Python command
line an object model that maps anything
that exists within this virtual rosette
the hub cloud so that you will have an
object in Python which is a machine that
maps any machine on any cloud you can
access you will have kind of rappers
that would allow you to automate and
program with infrastructure the way you
program with data so another part of the
contract is to say what we want is
having these engine engines make the
cloud a place for collaboration and
real-time interaction between users so
basically if
use one talk to this broker to create
this instance of server movie in which
there is this engine that can and talk
to our and Python this user wants to
collaborate with a colleague on the
other side of the globe all it takes is
today to tell the broker that there are
other users who are entitled to access
that same session that same engine and
then immediately all the users allowed
will be accessing the same virtual
session it's like having a Jupiter
notebook that will be seen by the same
at the same time by different people who
can view and edit so that's that's the
contract what we want as well is to use
the fact that we have full control on
these engines to introduce it to
introduce as as much traceability
reproducibility as we can in this
platform so basically that engine that
you allocate and interact with remotely
will be capturing every single thing you
asked for so if you you you talk to the
agent and an address the Python
personality saying please load this data
we will capture this this task a kind of
what docker does when you create the
dockerfile there are steps from going to
end from A to B and if you have that
list of steps anyone can reproduce what
you've done so we introduced this notion
we there is a database that you can look
inside and get exactly what who does who
did what in that particular engine and
of course that allow you to replay
things and of course we use to to the
maximum of their capabilities the notion
of virtual machine images docker images
in order to allow user one to go to this
broker to pull resources using their
identifiers and to get the session in
that browser from that session you can
create results you can create artifacts
and then tell the broker to
to create a bundle of those descriptors
and share them with anyone so you can
communicate everything related to your
environment to any user through this
broker by telling which image which
which storage it has been used which
version of Python which visual of our
and so on and so forth so let me let me
see if if internet works properly okay
so we are here a connecting so let's so
I went to wwc a hub com that's that's
where the platform leaves that this is
one of the views because it has also
other other perspective and other usage
scenario so you can you can already join
so it's the platform is meant to be free
the platform is meant to be a kind of
github for data size github allows you
to store your code and share it with
anyone and collaborate and create
incrementally amazing projects but what
is missing is the real time dimension
you cannot engage in a session with in
github like the session you would you'd
create using google docs you know Google
Docs is real time Jupiter is real time
interaction with a remote engine all
that is not in github what we want is to
say we need another hub where people
will be able using this broker to create
data science infrastructure to connect
to those infrastructures and to share
them and to basically complement github
with something that is open and
accessible and free so let me a sign in
maybe the internet is a bit slow
I can try to switch to another to
another Wi-Fi
is this one working yes
so I'm signing in
is internet slow for everyone or maybe
yeah so let me see
oh this is terrible
ok this one and what about this one it's
still loading ok let me probably try to
use the old platform I'm going to
elastic are calm let's see if it is any
better
okay so this is a old infrastructure so
let's see how it goes with this one so
let's let's have a look to what i get
when i connect to this to this portal
those who are familiar with ec2 would
would recognize like a similar layout i
have a dashboard that gives me a an idea
about all the resources i have so i have
currently one machine and inside that
machine i have one container and inside
that container have one engine so those
engines that can talk r and talk all the
the other languages so let me see how it
goes when i asked to list my machines
yeah i have a machine called the moshi
plex running on the cloud of google GCE
and it has this capacity hi i would like
to create a new one i will click on
launch and this takes me through as a
workflow a first step is to choose my
infrastructure hey i'm going to say ok I
would like another machine on Google
compute engine I will choose the keys I
have already stored so anyone can store
keys on the infrastructure to be to
allow the infrastructure to act as a
broker the region is already set in the
keys basically the keys are related to
particularly in a region i would say ok
I would like this to be called demo PI
data for example and then I can choose
any capacity that is available on the
cloud of Google basically we expose
everything we expose any capacity that
Google has and we update this according
to the the evolution of the
infrastructure of Google I would cut the
system to shed to let me shut down
manually this this this instance and and
that's it I can review on lunch and that
will create a new machine on Google's
infrastructure if I would like to be
more specific on how this machine should
look like I'll do next here at this at
this level I can tell the platform to
attach to the machine any storage I may
want to use it could be attached my HDFS
cluster or attach my
three buckets and those will become my
working directories that they can
interact with direct from Python or are
or whatever so I will I will keep
working locally next at this level I can
tell the platform how to what is the
topology inside the machine that I would
like to work with the apology here is
about containers and engines why I would
want something complicated imagine that
you are going to launch a big machine
inside which you would like 30 separated
environment for your 30 students and you
want everyone to be working
independently in sandboxed context then
you would say ok create 30 containers
and for each container the loot there
will be one injured and in your latest
step you can say please make these 30
containers shared with this group so the
user john will have the first container
user Nancy we have the second container
and they will be able to have the proper
work bench independently from the others
so here let's keep the basic mode next
step I will be specifying who with whom
I would like to share I can do it later
of course when the machine is running I
can say ok I would like it besides the
Rosetta engines I would like to be using
our studio I would like to be using
ipython I would like VNC to be enabled
so these are extra tools to the platform
that can be made accessible next here
because this machine is going to be run
on a cloud with my credentials and
potentially I can share it with anyone I
can share it with my students I need to
make sure that the the costs are under
control basically what can alter the
costs apart from the capacity is the
data in data out so if they upload a
terabyte then the cost will be not the
1i have expected for this particular
instance so you can create a threshold
so here we go
and and then I will not put a threshold
that will review what asked for and
lunch so this workflow is agnostic to
which cloud you are talking to it will
be the same if it is your OpenStack
cluster OpenStack local private cloud so
you see here there is a new machine
called demo PI data which status estate
is pending it will go from pending to
starting and from starting to running
like this one here the more cplex and
when it is running that means I have the
possibility to go and have a virtual
session with the engine running inside
you see the Machine wanted to starting I
have already won running I don't know if
it is in in a good shape you can wait
for the other one but let me connect to
this one and see how it goes yeah so
basically inside this machine if this is
a machine I Allah i launched yesterday
within this machine I have already some
views so you see here I am interacting
so this is a view of a console and this
is a view of the graphics of the
technical involve a technical computing
one time working with so for instance
here i can create variables by talking
to the our personality of the engine so
i would create a variable X equal a norm
of 100 I will create a variable y equal
100 element of the normal distribution
again and I will plot x against why so
the the plot I have just created
actually has been created within a
virtual device to which Python can write
which Julia can write which any
personality of the engine can write what
is what what what in which how is this
different from from Jupiter when it
comes to using different environment
here it's only one process that talks to
all of them if i switch to python it's
going to be python in this
same virtual java virtual machine that
actually has the same memory and i can
get my x and y directly push to python I
can do let's let's switch to python here
we go and let's create another variable
Z equal 12 45 so now I'm interacting
with Python all of this is in the same
memory I would like to instead of using
these views i will be using for example
a component that will be like a floating
notebook cell so here we go i asked for
the notebook cell component inside this
notebook cell component i can put some
our codes i will draw an Instagram of X
and if I would like to a switch to to
python let me go and and grab some
matplotlib gallery let's take an example
from Python here we go tak I'll take the
script and paste it
and execute so now the cell is yeah so
this talk to the personality the Python
personality to get me to get me this
result at any point in time I can make
this accessible to any user of the
platform i can say share and if I
specify the user with whom to share for
example I will be sharing this with
Latifah and i will give Latifah all the
rights to administrate that particular
engine I'm sharing with her so here we
go so Latifah became entitled to access
the same thing so i will open another
browser and connect to elastic are as as
latifah yep here we go
and let me put these side by side done
okay so you see here that Latifah has
one shared engine so I go and have a
look that shared engine is the one I
have just shared with her it's a machine
called demo suplex that is running the
last version of Santos and I I can hear
on the right you have Latifah and on the
left you have you have me ergo so what
we will have in the two browsers is
access to the same engine and everything
that is done by any of the connected
users will be seen and unaccessible to
the others so let's internet is really
terribly slow but anyway if it doesn't
work basically what what what this is
about it's about making the tools that
you currently use all of them accessible
into one single location so it's like
one stop shop for data science
capabilities and infrastructures what
this is about is making you able to
empower extend your existing code your
existing tools by up working with the
api's and it's coming it's really really
slow you see that on the right sheet1 is
coming and when when okay here we go
notebook shell yes coming okay so here
we go and and you see every action i
have on the right will be seen on the
left let me change here n 2 to 300
and you see that it's a collaborative
editor that that anything done on the
right is is similarly accessible on the
left all actions here are our broadcast
to all connected user so there are there
are loads of features in this platform
it's it's going to be ready in the
coming few weeks for its first beta I
advise you to go and register you will
have tokens to run machines on different
clouds for free and and later on you'll
be able to put your keys inside the
platform to create a spark lusters to
create collaborate a collaboration
environment to access Jupiter or or or
our studio if you wish so please go to
ww LS dot rosetta hub com register and
let's keep in touch thank you very much
for it
you